bonsoir bienvenue sur le plateau du 7 8
il est 18h si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur TVfil 78 et voici les titres
de cette édition du 23 janvier les
titres en images la mobilisation des
syndicats d'enseignants contre la
réforme payant présenté ce mercredi ce
que craignent surtout ces syndicats
c'est la difficulté de mise en oeuvre
des nouveaux rythmes scolaires toujours
en matière d'éducation zoom sur les
cordées de la réussite un dispositif qui
associe collège lycée et établissement
d'enseignement supérieur exemple le
lycée de la plaine de nos flat attrape
les chiffres de la sécurité pour 2012
publier le nombre de cambriolages
toujours en augmentation plus 6% c'est
toutefois moins qu'en 2011 précise le
préfet Michel Joe que vous avez aperçu
elle est service de police s'appelle
l'ensemble de la population la plus
grande vigilance une conséquence plus
inattendue de la neige les retards pour
passer le permis de conduire des retards
accentués par la grève des inspecteurs
reportage dans une auto-école à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et puis dans une
vingtaine de minutes également comme
chaque mercredi à la chronique la
culture avec Johanna Soudry bonsoir
Johanna et ce soir nous aurons un groupe
à découvrir et puis également à
découvrir made in trap c'est le premier
livre d'Alain Degois papiers le
fondateur de Déclic Théâtre exactement
alors ça va swinguer avec un jeune
groupe il s'appelle les bazars et bémol
et sortent leur deuxième EP et puis
comme vous l'avez dit Alain Degois dit
papi directeur artistique de trappes de
trappes de déclicate attrape viendra
donc présenter son premier livre qui
s'appelle made in trap merci Johanna on
vous retrouve dans une vingtaine de
minutes et justement pour parler
également de cette question des Talents
des Cités puisque c'est la thématique du
livre d'Alain de Guan nous rejoindra
Asie seni les chefs d'entreprise hommes
politiques originaire de Mantes-la-Jolie
il est aussi l'auteur de monte ton biz
et l'ascenseur social est en panne j'ai
pris l'escalier dans un instant le point
sur l'action du ONG evelinoise au Mali
action Mopti avec Didier Ouedrago sont
chargés de mission mais éducation pour
l'instant pour débuter ce nouveau 7 8 du
23 janvier
la mobilisation des syndicats
d'enseignants contre la réforme du
ministre Vincent Peillon présenté ce
mercredi il manifestait aujourd'hui à
Paris vous allez le voir dans un instant
dans leur ligne de mire les rythme
scolaire explication Valérie Auribeau et
le dimanche une réforme des rythmes
scolaires oui dans ces conditions non
c'est le mot d'ordre lancé par le
syndicat des enseignants du premier
degré ce mercredi à Trappes jour de
manifestations régionales de l'ensemble
des départements d'Île-de-France l'idée
de réformer les rythmes scolaires est
une bonne idée nous défendons un projet
de transformation de l'école mais cette
transformation doit être doit se
traduire par une amélioration à la fois
des conditions de travail des élèves
bien entendu mais aussi des conditions
de travail des enseignants or le décret
proposé par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Vincent Peillon n'apporte pas
suffisamment de garantie selon ce
syndicat d'enseignant là on a plutôt à
faire un calendrier qui se fait à marche
forcée donc qui a peu de chance de
comment dirais-je de permettre
l'élaboration de projets construits et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
l'Association des maires de France
d'ailleurs c'est aussi prononcer contre
la mise en place à la rentrée 2013 les
maires de gauche comme de droite
estiment que les délais imposés par le
décret sont difficiles à tenir pour la
rentrée prochaine les budgets pour 2013
étant déjà voté à Guyancourt par exemple
le maire socialiste François de Lignier
a déjà programmé la modification des
rythmes scolaires pour 2014 de son côté
l'académie de Versailles annonce la
création de 74 postes d'enseignants pour
septembre prochain dans le premier degré
éducation toujours mais sous un autre
angle nous allons à nous focaliser à
présent sur les cordées de la réussite
en dispositif qui associe collège lycée
et établissement d'enseignement
supérieur un exemple au lycée de la
plaine de Neauphle c'est à Trappes donc
là on a décomposé la lumière blanche et
on voit toutes les couleurs des ateliers
pour apprendre à aimer les sciences
proposer aux élèves du lycée de la
plaine de Neauphle par des étudiants
l'établissement adhère depuis 2010 au
dispositif des Cordées de la réussite
d'Ariane à 14 ans elle est volontaire
depuis un an on va visiter différentes
choses pas les découvertes ou des musées
et
fait des visites une cordée en termes de
montagne c'est le lien qui unit les
alpinistes les cordées de la réussite en
termes scolaire c'est la même chose des
établissements d'enseignements
supérieurs nous des partenariats avec
des collèges et lycées
issus de zones d'éducation prioritaire
l'intérêt de décorer de la réussite
c'est aussi d'avoir des jeunes qui
transmettent c'est à dire que les jeunes
qui sont encore des des tuteurs qui sont
des étudiants des têtes de cordée donc
nous avons dans le département 78 comme
tête de cordée d'université de
Saint-Quentin nous avons HEC nous avons
un gros ParisTech et nous avons trois is
le tutorat marche vraiment bien on le
sait autant d'ailleurs dans cette
expérience là que dans la vie normale
d'un établissement ou bien souvent un
aîné aide un plus jeune ici à Trappes 40
élèves en bénéficient et comme parrain
l'établissement compte par exemple le
prestigieux lycée parisien Janson de
Sailly la caractéristique des élèves de
la ville de Trappes c'est que ils ont
tendance à être un peu résignés par
rapport à leur parcours et d'où
l'intérêt des cornets de la réussite au
justement on doit donner de l'ambition à
nos élèves c'est vraiment une une
aventure humaine très enrichissante que
ce soit de la part des étudiants qui
viennent chez nous de nos élèves aussi
et même pour les adultes donc les
différents acteurs c'est des moments
privilégiés d'échanges que nous
n'aurions très certainement pas
l'occasion d'avoir en dehors des Cordées
de la réussite l'intérêt c'est donc la
transmission entre jeunes de témoignages
et de savoir pour entraîner l'émulation
dans le département une cinquantaine de
lycées et une vingtaine de collèges
participent à ses cordées